[Music]
hello everyone
uh the topic of for today's lesson is
decision making
any complex positions
during the game
you get
positions
where you need
how to make
decisions there are so many critical
positions during the game that every
time
you need to make your choice
I would like to show you
how to
make decisions
on the example of my game played in
U.S Senior Championship 2000
22 versus uh
Grandmaster Larry Christensen
I play it with white
and I play D4 Knight F6
C4
E6
Knight F3 G5 Knight CS3 A6
this interesting
opinion
which is quite popular nowadays and
actually uh Larry Christensen already
played this line
against me
in the in one of the previous U.S Senior
championships
until
this moment we
repeated our previous game where
already played Bishop p7
after Castle Rock C1
okay
black
got a good position
uh with a good encounter play uh later
he played C5 Rook C8 and
uh game ended in a draw
uh
in this game
he decided
to play more actually Bishop G6
however
This Plane is also very similar to the
plan he played
a few years earlier
Okay so queso
green C2
H6
and here
we get the first critical position
where
we need to make your decision
there are two natural moves for a while
Bishop H4 and Bishop F4
Bishop F4
a very interesting idea
to
trade dark Square Bishops which is a
good forward
in this position in in this structure
pound structure
Bishop takes F4 it takes F4 is quite
dangerous for black because now a white
is citizen to play F5
also he is
ready to create attack on the key inside
and to occupy e file
so black has to play for example
for cleaner 7
and we get
a position uh well-known position
with a pound minority attack on the
queen side
after dark Square Bishop trade white can
play
Rook B1 before
a plane on the green side
this was possible but I decided
to play Bishop H4
the pin of the Knight
F6 is still
on the board so Bishop H4 is
also possible
it first played Rock
8 A3
C5
otherwise
what
is playing before stopping C5
align and uh
black doesn't have a counter play in the
center
after C5 black
is going to play with
isolated deep bound
and here after d takes C5 Knight takes
C5
we get
another critical position what to do
for white
uh black is going to trade
the Knight for a light Square Bishop
Waters
uh what should white do whether white
needs to
keep his bishop and G3 trading for the
night or
he has to avoid the straight also uh I
see there is a question in the chat
uh why a white Place C4 take C5 here
because first of all
a black can play roxy8 anyway
uh gradient pressure in the center but
also uh
Black's plan can be to play C5 C4 and
then B7 B5
getting the space on the queen side
that's why uh G takes C5 is very natural
and here in this position
I needed to decide how to continue
so uh White can play here Rook G1
a plane against
accelerated bound and also there is a
plan with Bishop F5
and probably a rook G1
Rook 81 was the best choice for example
after
roxied
a white place can be one
awarding
would pin on the C file
and then
white is going to double Rooks on G file
uh he is control
default Square
and it seems that a White's position is
slightly better here
but instead of Rogue one
I decided
to force
Black Knight
either to capture on G3 or to uh
play back to G7 I played before
what
I can say about this move
this is
quite
dangerous for what because now uh
squaresive 4 is a weak forever
but uh
black
is I needed to decide to make his
decision what to do
after Knight takes D3 Queen takes D3
uh White
as controlling Central Square G4 and
probably he has a slight advantage
uh
putting Knight on D4 maybe to
uh bring his knight from C3 to E2 also
the pin of the Knight on F6 is quite
unpleasant for a black
and
this position seems is
slightly better for white again
so Blake decided to play
Knight cg7
and what can be a Black's plan here
first of all he is fighting for C file
Rook C8
is the next idea
and how
to continue
it's a
clear that after Roxette white will need
to move his
Queen from C2
but what is better to put rocks on D
file or to play Roxy 1 or kc1 then after
roxy8 to move for queen
to B2 for example and to play to fight
for the C file
in this position
I played Rook a to D1
I think that uh
Rook a to C1 could be
more precise
because after oxide Queen B2
I can put another Rook on G1 and also
white is ready to fight for the C file
after Knight E2
and then probably trying to trade
dark Square Bishops after Bishop G3
and also
getting a very good Square for the
Knight
uh C3 E4 after uh that square Bishop
so
probably Rook C1
was better than Rook D1 but let's look
what happened next
Rook 81
roxy8
Queen B2
Queen C7
here it's another critical position
uh I just played Rook a to D1 and it
seems that uh Rook C1
uh
just wasting time
so probably the best way was to play
Knight to this idea
Bishop G3
trading dark Square Bishops
but I I decided to play here Rook C1
Fortune almost Fortune green Beast beard
and now Bishop G3
what
could you say about Bishop just remove
in this position
is it uh
a good move or it was better to play
Knight E2 with idea Bishop G3 because
after Bishop takes G3 a stage G3 what is
getting a double pounds and it's unclear
where the pound
is better placed on ah file or on G3 on
G3
ah
in the game
position of the Powerman yesterday was
decisive
and you will see
why sometimes double Pawns
I can be
weak
and even this
detail because of this detail you can
watch the game
so probably
what should have played here uh
92
and then preparing Bishop G3 trading the
Bishops
but after Bishop the G3 Bishop takes G3
H takes G3
black is playing
Knight E5
and what to do for white what is Black's
idea
through the
Ella Black Knight to go to C4
or I need to trade the knights
white can trade knives here but I was
afraid
after Queen takes E5 I was afraid of
a very strong
threat uh
black is going
to move his Queen to H5
and then
Knight G4
what should white do
to pair This Thread and uh
how white can play
the Knight is pinned so if white plays
for example Knight A4 then Queen H5 is
very strong move this idea
uh Knight G4 then
and in the game
Arjun go to the Slime I didn't take uh
195
because
I didn't like this idea but white has
a strong continuation and actually uh
he can play cringe2 here
the idea is after Knight E4 to trade a
bishop and then to bring his Knight to
D4 but of course black can equalize here
is the left and 94 take take
Knight E2 he can play simply Bishop
C4 trading for the Knight and this end
game
ah is absolutely equal
but after a clean defy Queen G2 black
and play kinesh5 what
what can do in this case Knight G4 is
very strong
thread
so what a white can do
and
F3 here is dangerous because a pounds
around white king will be awake if if
you Wave 3 here then G3 pound is three
pounds ah
ah where we you can start to play with
Queen G5 attacking G3 and E3 pounds and
it's not so easy uh
to defend uh all bounds also instead of
King G5 there is screen E5
uh more which is which can be even
stronger
instead of F3 white has
move here
the idea that after
an ig4 white can trade this night but
what to do after a bishop G4
can you suggest
a move here
actually Bishop G4 is a blunder in this
position
and how white can
use this bundle
yeah F3 is possible but after black
move his Bishop from G4 again pounds on
E3 and G3 will be big but it
seems that Knight takes D5 is possible
and this is a tactical manure and avoid
wins a pound here why this move is
possible here
after Bishop takes E2
white has
double attack
Knight F4
kin the queen and the bishop and white
gets extra pound
after
uh Knight takes D5 white can play Bishop
takes G4 again
white is winning a pound
so
it was possible to trade Knights only
five and to play Queen G2
but uh
and in this position
I needed to make a decision whether to
C4 or not I decided that uh
my position would not be
worse in that case and I can get the
chances to gain some initiative I played
by Bishop with two uh probably uh
better move was even Rook F2 G1
is the same idea
uh
I put the black snide to C4 but uh
I I would get the same position as in
the game but with extra temper so rock
fd1 these are
serious attention here
so I played Bishop with two
Knight C4
what to do here
uh when I played the bishop E2 I was
ready to capture Knight on C4
uh creation
uh very strong past pound C4 for black
but in this case
I would
get
a possibility to
fight for IFA for the G file open G file
and uh what
would be another Choice here
another choice is so
hello a Black Knight
to stay on a C4 square but
trying to
create threads on the G file for example
I could play Queen A1 B5 and now
white is ready
to double Rooks on G file Rook D1 Rook
G4
and this position is approximately equal
uh this standard position
where a white is playing against
isolated bound
but my idea was to open up a d file
even
given
an opportunity for black to create a
very strong past bound
Bishop takes him for detail C4
a rock F2 G1
Bishop F5 black is going to put his
bishop and G3
and what to do now
Knight on C3 is very good
because it's excellent blocking piece
but how to react if black
uh we'll be able to put his Bishop on G4
on G3 sorry
I played uh Rook G4
Rook it to G8 Rook C to D1
Bishop G3
and here ah
you get another critical position
what to do
the Knight
uh
accessory should be placed on C3 to
block the pawn
on C4
uh
how to fight for the D file here
and I decided to create
isolated pound for white here I played
Knight E1
and now
after Rook date is D4
Bishop F5
as this another critical position where
you need to decide
whether d-pawn is
strong or weak
so when I try to evaluate this position
I
saw that
white is not
worse he is not at least worse and upon
on D5
passed deep on might be very strong in
this position however after Clinic 2
now rookie it is not possible because uh
pound on C4 is Kenyan
so black played
Queen G6
and I played greenify
offering a clearance trade and at the
same time after quintase G5 detects E5
White
is been the struggle for the D file so
black played here Queen G7
D5
how to continue
uh
White's pound might be very strong here
and black
is needed
to create counter play
so he played Rook 8.
24 B5
Knight F3
Queen G6
what would you say about this position
what is White's plan here
and how white
use
the his
pan on G5
first of all black
foreign
but the Korean is not the best
piece the block past power
and what uh White should do here Queen
on G6
cannot be
a good piece
not on G6 would be much better
and a white
is going
to
win a fight for the G6 Square he is
playing Queen C5
now
what to do if
a black place
it can be
here then G6
and Pawn
became even stronger
and now
the bishop ski engine the Knight is
going
to
E5
after Bishop G4
Rook D4 Rook c85
locate King F4 Knight
foreign
and black is almost forced to trade
this bishop Bishop to the Knight and
after G takes F3 you can see how strong
is Japan
G6 pound for example after Rock did
King G2
Rook G7
E5
is unclear uh what to do
White's idea is to break
a pound structure black spawn structure
on the queen side he can play
for example of the queen B7
A4
and it's very hard
to defend this position
uh
the example
can be with this A4
takes on C4 A3
this upon can be annoying for white but
here
he has enough time to create series Rook
C7
8 Queen C5 for example
Unified
and now a white Australian
rocks green C6 his version pound on G6
but the collection of both pounds A6
and A3
and at the end the white gets positioned
with extra power
if
after Queen C5
black base
this happened in the game and here uh
another critical position
what to do for white how
he can develop
his initiative
and uh
in this position I
talk
around decision
uh
I found uh
a plan which looked very strong
after uh
green trade
Green Street I was going to put my Rook
on D4 and then
a break
black spell instructions like a queen
side of the A4
unfortunately I didn't find the best way
here
in this critical position
and the best way was to play
94.
and after Bishop G3
White
is going to lose his deep five pound
restaurant past pound
but uh
there is an option
to save this power and to create a very
strong
attack
white can
play Knight C6 here
okay uh opponent D5
uh still is not protected but now a
white has Stamper
ah because rokan
Jade skankin in this position
a
black
has
Rook G7 move rookie one
uh suddenly
a Pawn on D5
is protected at this moment because
uh Knight D5 is not possible because of
Fort Fork on a seven
uh at the end of the variation
so a black
should fight
find a way how uh
to create thread to respawn but it's
unclear what to do there are many moves
here
and black has to make his decision and
let's look what would happen uh in this
position
he has first of all uh what if
black trades
Queens B takes C5 now G6 is very strong
so roxy7
is the only move
and uh White
he has two moves here night before
and another move which is probably the
best one Knight B
now A5
is bad because of C6
and white pounds are extremely strong
so our black has to trade
pounds
and it would be the same position as uh
this night before
96
roxy8
night before black can play here okay
okay one and white
still has a past bound and his plan is
very simple
uh
B5 is Canyon and if
black protects it then white plays F3
and then King F2 kidney 3 King G4
ah engagen restaurant position in the
center and a very nice
working nights on before nc3 and it
seems that white has
restaurant initiative and he has
advantage in this position
so let's look what else they can do
it's uh
if he plays a killer shade it wasn't
uh
Forks red 37 and now attacking
pound
on D5
after this white can play 95.
and black cannot protect F7 Square
because his Queen
uh should be protected Rook d8 is the
only move
Queen takes C5 is bad because
now white case
after B takes C5 Knight is attacking a
rook and
white I can say
both
past pounds
so rock dates and negative and takes F7
uh foreign
again
moving his skin out of the fork on S7
again Knight F5 is very strong and after
G8
White
has another very strong idea he can play
Queen A7 here
and it's unclear how to
defend
out of green takes F7 thread for example
if Knight G7 here then simply 96 and
pounds
on the queen side
are Fallen King Texas 6 then upon on B5
is gaining
so
you can fade
is also bad
so what else
ah Bishop j6 is possible
uh this idea just to wait but after
oroki 5 now the pound on D5 is protected
and White Plain White's plan is simply
to bring his skin to the center he can
play for example H5 F3 q97 King F2
and here if Bishop G3 then even kidney
three uh is possible this idea just to
trade Rooks and then to bring his skin
to D4 and C5
also H5 move
can be met with uh Knight F5
rogate and again very strong
idea Q A7
and now black has two moves
he can play either Rock f8 protection
power on F7 or
to create a trap for white now rookie
now Queen takes F7
is not uh so good because after
King H7
Knight takes D3
Rook desi1
black has greenify more Western move
Queen file attacking boss Knights and
black has chances to equalize here
but after okay white can simply
take on G3
now Our Queen on A7 and after Rook takes
E1
Knight X E1 Queen E5 is not working
because of Q and S3 move
defendant boss Knights and after C takes
the three
simply
taken on E8 Knight eat King 3 Knight F6
King G3 white against the power
so
you see how strong
was the plan with 94 but now uh
also Cafe
possible but in this position white
still has very strong initiative he can
play
96 back in H7
Rook E5
and uh uh in a white has
almost decisive advantage and uh
even after
this short white has a very nice
combination he can take on H5 King G6
and Knight takes D5
taken
H5 and 24 uh
a black has extra exchange here but he
does have
a defense out of white threads the main
thread is
the simplest threat is Knight F4 check
within the queen
but also there is another thread
a clean H4 and Knight
37 creation imagine net
and black does have any difference
out of this thread for example after
rocket
check
and white against the queen because
leaking does have
squares
to move
so
it seems that after 94 move
here
a white head a big Advantage but during
the game
uh I took a wrong decision
I
captured on uh G6 Rook G6
Rook G4
Bishop C8
with a straight Bishop B7 within the
pound on the
five and here I
went to this position
plan can take G6 because
I saw
a nice opportunity for white
I played A4
breaking uh
the pawns on the queen side probably
this plan was correct but white needed
to prepare
in the time travel
when
I had to make
five more moves
for probably five minutes
uh I didn't find this opportunity and
white
could play 92 here
what is so wise idea
what white can do
if
a black plays Bishop B7
audition how to save the pound on G5
if Knight E4 then
black simply caption default on e4 Rock
takes E4 can f8
upon uh
on G5 will be weak because you then
don't have
pieces
to defend this part in G5 and a black is
going just to play King 7 and then to
bring his King to
G6 to remove his Rock from G6 and
to put his skin
before the pawn
so
or what is White's idea
what should he do
it seems that white has
a F4 is possible all right but it will
be the same position as in the game but
the idea of Knight d2 move was
that the white has Knight F1
move and now
a pound
on G5 is protected because if black
captures spawn on G5 then after Knight
is 3
the piece on G5
would be appeared and white idea here is
to put Knight on E3 and only after that
he can play
A4
a break-in on the pound chain on the
queen side
instead of this I played A4 immediately
and here
this
idea is not well prepared black plays
btx A4
and here uh I needed to make another
decision what to do my idea was to play
Knight E5 here
and I saw a variation A3 Knight takes
C4 A2
uh Rook G1
Rock
and ah
is going to d8 for example then G6
or even I can play uh Knight
B6 and Knight takes A2 so white is uh
better here but suddenly uh
when I calculating this variation I
found that black can play Rook D5
and in the time travel I didn't see how
I can
save
my position after Knight takes D5 Knight
takes D5
then black is going to cut Japan on uh
before then Bishop P6 with register on
A2 I thought also Bishop F5 Bishop of B1
threat I didn't see how to save the game
so
I needed to make a quick decision here
and probably the best way was just
to try to make a draw
White
had rocked AC4 move attacking the bishop
Bishop B7 and now white could simply
catch upon
of course he
a lot of his
a very strong past the G pound but at
least
white could
equalize
in this position
so probably this was the best
way for white
after uh taken a wrong decision with
Queen straight on G6
but I decided to continue my plan Knight
E5
phase three
very strong move
Knight C4 A2
and here
this
three moves
left until time control
I needed to make another
very tough decision
as I showed you my first intention was
Rook D1 but I overlooked Rook takes D5
Australia
and another
decision I need to make whether I can
save the game after Knight takes A2
and
of course if
I would not see chances after Knight
takes it to Rook Place D5 where
black Bishop would be extremely strong
with the pounds on the both sides
uh
I I I would play Rook D1 in this
position and I I would try to
find
uh
the idea how to hold position and uh it
seems that white has
uh his pieces set up where uh
he could make a draw uh look after
Knight takes D5 Knight takes D5
the best Square for the night is A3 and
when I put my knight on a three
uh
B1 square is under control so uh Black's
ideal I guess black thread with Bishop
F5
and Bishop B1
uh
would be
I would not be so strong for example
after a night before
I can bring kin
Bishop F5
Rook A1
now this will be one is a thread but
after okay one uh White has Simple Plan
he can uh
put his
okay next to the center or to be too
Square uh in the future after F3 and kin
hon B2 would be
you've got a pound and uh when a White
Rock
is
free then white you can easily make a
draw
in this position despite very strong
upon 182 and you see how uh Knight on S3
can be
useful here
it uh controls both critical squares B1
and C2
so this was the way how white could
play for a draw but
I found another uh idea how to save the
game and uh
probably because I found this idea I
lost the game my idea was uh
to trade rocks Knight takes A2
Rook days D5
Rook 3 is D5 Knight takes D5
and now uh it was
very important critical position and it
was the last move Before Time control
and I needed
to make my decision I have three
opportunities
first opportunity is to trade Knights
only three
uh after Knight takes is three F takes
C3 it looks like white
uh
is created
The Fortress
here can put 92 C3
and then
he can simply play Kinect one can G1
and black
on the first side uh black cannot break
this Fortress
if a black process Canton G4S and the
skin F2 a white can play with his Knight
so
first of all I need to decide whether
this position is Fortress
another
position I need to decide whether the
Fortress Is with bounds on F2 G2 and G3
in the game I played Knight G6 here
decided
deciding that this position is Fortress
as well Knight F4 then 93 93 963
and how Auto break this position uh wise
plan is to play F3
and then I'm putting my king
33
it was played in The Game King 7 F3 King
G6 King F2 can a 5 king 3. I thought
that this also a fortress
because ah black does have squares to
penetrate to the queen side
and also he cannot break
on the king side
but also it was the third opportunity in
this position and probably
it was one of the best positions again
white could put his Knight
on the edge of the board it was possible
to play Knight A3
uh what is widespan here
the difference between position with
knights on the board and without noise
is that uh black does have
uh opportunity to trade the bishop for
the night in the game a bishop could
stay on B5 with Knight on C3 and white
white could not trade and go to the
pound engine because
of double pound
double pounds on the inside a white
position uh would be lost
and here after 93 Knight T3 can fade can
F1 Bishop G7 kidney two uh Bishop B5
is not working because Knight's end game
here is equal
94 F3
Channel 7 King G3 and here a white has
all chances to make a draw so it is my
Fortress move
I need to make a very hard decision
where to go or
in
which position can be drawn and which
position is lost
so ah
I afraid
I was afraid to play 93 here and I was
my decision was correct because uh in
this position there is no Fortress
uh one a black can break this folders
after F5
Knight C3
King F7
tnf2 Bishop j7 King G1 King 6 King F2
Bishop C6 and now
black simply
breaks uh this Fortress after G5 uh
and here white is in tooks one
if it would be a Black's position he
cannot play F4 because I can uh capture
device on F4 and after G3 to create
uh the real Fortress because I take
kidney F5
uh chemistry uh all
squares
are controlled with the white pieces and
a black cannot win but in this position
a white has to play King G1 and after F4
G takes F4 Kim takes F4
there is no G3 checking is not on uh F2
and there is no G3 check
and a black wins after can F2 kmfi and
he is
penetration to the queen side to win a
pound before and this end game is lost
for white
so here I was lucky that I I played
King G6
and went to this position
kidney seven King G6 kidney five Guinea
three
H5
kindly check on B5 now our pound engine
is lost here because
a black Plan would be G5 H4 and then
this Canon S3
white would be in socks one
can
some of the F4 G3 exam we're in power
engine or and white cannot save position
so
akinatory I saw that this is a
Fortress but the black
has excellent idea here he plays Bishop
F1
and now
after King F2
he has
very strong candy for move
and uh
now a white doesn't have any difference
so with this idea
black
won the game and I would like
uh to offer this position as a home work
for you could find an excellent
opportunity for white here
to create a for real Fortress in this
position
um
I I would like
to
continue
uh
to analyze this position and uh
where
you can make
this critical position where you can
make a fantastic decision
uh
on the next
class
on the next week
so I think if you can find an excellent
opportunity in this position it would be
very useful for you and also this idea
is
excellently nice
thank you for joining us
and
see you next week
on the grandmaster's choice and I will
show you
the decision in this position
thank you
[Music]